[Musique]
un point d'eau pour 500 habitants ici
commence le bidonville de conflans
sainte honorine le bras favé à 30 km de
paris
rive gauche le bidonville rive droite la
ville
ce bidonville est installés légalement
la limite de deux communes conflent et
hr
où
tu dois t'en veux coutal facebook
les sturm l'une des dix familles
françaises du bidonville le père ancien
marinier a préféré débarquer en 1966
pour vivre avec ses neuf enfants dont 5
encore au foyer un vieil autocar acheté
deux cent vingt mille anciens francs
chez un ferrailleur
mariage 13 ans valérie 15 mois
pascal 19 ans
monsieur sturm et guti à la ville de
paris
frédéric 21 ans
thierry six ans inadapté
madame sturm la mer
didier 10 ans charlie 15 ans est absent
il faut bien comment travailler pour
voir pour les gosses
ce que ça mange bien les gosses un pur
pas les arts privé egos de manger aux
rémois suis pas comme certains compris
vous des gosses j'ai mieux travailler
puis mes enfants on va manger
[Musique]
de vivre comme la commune et c'est pas
une vie
on dirait qu'on les escarres quand même
voir tous les maisons
des maisons en bois là tout ça
vous progresser pour des clochards
plutôt beaucoup
l'inclusion et c'est encore mieux logé
que nous que des fois pas vrai
[Applaudissements]
moi aussi j'aurais de l'argent je
m'astreins dujardin pis bâtiment qui tue
maintenant que j'aurais pas de jardin
mais tant que j'aurai une petite maison
dessus
pas dire une villa
[Applaudissements]
ou ne put jamais l'autobus jamais jeunes
quittent
parce qu'on aura la maison du temps ils
demandent de charlie marie c'est des
enfants mais contre qui ne sont pas
comme les autres quand même
[Musique]
comme ça qu'on nous a dit si vous voulez
si vous restez là c'est parce que vous
voulez bien
j'ai trouvé des logements meublés donner
une reprise au moins de 3 400 mille
francs alors c'est de l'argent quand
même qu'il faut avoir la sous la main
[Applaudissements]
maison c'est déjà beaucoup plus grand on
ne peut avoir plusieurs pièces
ici on en a deux d'accord parce que nos
fils séparation
dans une maison et quand même vraiment
ce soir ici on parle on peut les
entendre des eaux
le côté du pont les gens se promènent
leurs épouses
et les enfants se promènent mal et ils
vont à l'école propres
critères viennent d'écoles sarlino midi
là mais tu m'as fait une réflexion j'ai
mes chaussures sales alors oui il m'a
dit qu'il valait plus je retourne il y
avait dix d'une pure tourne à l'école
existe sur sal
j'aimerais bien là où leur dire depuis
que les enfants vont à l'école j'ai
jamais remonter là où on nous regardait
tous à
[Musique]
deir alla mais la côtoie la montée hier
on les voyait courir la lenteur des
maisons là j'en ai déjà eu deux draps
ici et là petite elle avait à peu près
15 jours elle a été si ça ils ont été
ses synthés de julio y voyaient leurs
pattes
avant je mettais mes légumes d or je
l'aimé depuis mon retour au bout de
terre carottes immense tous les chemins
ça ne me dit ne sait pas lire ni écrire
pour les enfants il est bon aussi bien
que pour moi ça fait quand même 24 ans a
su marier il n'est pas méchant rien du
tout jamais jamais été battu rien du
tout j'aime bien ces enfants étaient
toujours si j'achète quelque chose il
est tout à fait d'accord avec moi si
c'est lui je suis d'accord avec lui
pour les enfants c'est pareil quand ils
veulent quelque chose bien le père et
c'est lui qui décide et bien quand il y
aura ça il ne la gt voit pas tout de
suite mais enfin quand on peut on le
fait
la plupart des familles menacées refuse
de partir elles ont peur du pillage
ouah
certains habitants comme ce vieux
mariniers malades sont évacués malgré
eux
à
[Musique]
ou pas
frannie comme di nallo seigneur filet
alors j'ai moi-même suivi le mouvement
voilà arrêté autour de son école quant à
l'homme qui suivait il est revenir les
bruits et y est entré dans les locaux de
la dst j'ai des crises et thomas müller
qui m'a confirmé il s'agit bien de
l'inspecteur la dst et le mulet n'aura
pas une taxe avec no mi ser la dst
terminée
[Musique]
je suis d'être respecté par
les eaux dans les îles
[Musique]
informations vcu dr edward leurs épaules
bishara la scène a continué aujourd'hui
ça montait 5 m de 50 ce matin contre 5
mètres 30 les six mètres seront
prochainement atteint et ce sera là la
cote maximum la scène restera et allez
encore quelques jours avant de commencer
sa décrue à paris la situation n'a aucun
caractère de gravité
en seine et marne il semble que là ce n
est pas ce soir sa cote maximum vers
l'yonne et le loin avoir une légère
décrue pas delepine renoue pas de ford
aux 24 heures du mans s'était dit
oui à les lignes
aubin
avec madame sturm nous avons fait les
comptes revenu mensuel salaires et
allocations familiales c'est 110 francs
pour cette personne dépenses chauffage
éclairage 113 francs nourriture 900
francs habillement 225 francs entretien
école santé 190 quand il reste 180
francs pour les autres dépenses et
l'imprévu
gibrat favet au centre de conflent il ya
1 km 500 3 fois par jour 500 mètres à
parcourir pour la corvée d'eau 40 litres
à chaque voyage
[Musique]
quelqu'un de malade la nuit personne ça
dérange les médecins ne se dérange moi
je n'ai jamais fait venir un parce que
je sais qu'il nouvelle viendra pas et
comme j'ai eu la petite scène il a dit
moi je ne peux pas rester je m'en vais
alors il est reparti
oui ça même pas que pays à 12,1 kathleen
rowling à l'ambulance et puis viendra la
chercher et ils ont téléphoné le but
lens et
la femme du café elle lui a dit à l'aube
où l'on salit pas là bas vous ne serez
pu en sortir tellement que sonné dans la
boue si on a quelqu'un de malade on peut
tout à fait bien payé je suis mise
enfants malades
j'étais hyper sonic comme ça en allant
dire qu'est ce qu'ils avaient leur prend
la température et en allant dire ce
qu'ils avaient et on me donner les
médicaments pour les soigner
j'accuse mon jeu pas eu de chance on a
peu de chance
on est vraiment dans
la déveine dans tout parce que nous
sommes une chance à rien si on a des
enfants enfin qui sont pas qu'ils sont
bien portants et tout malheureusement
pour thierry qui a cinq mois c'est pas
qu'on a échoué non mais je pense qu'on
aurait quand même pu être plus hauts
fourneaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'école et nous dit tu veux que les
portugais tout ça moi je dis j'y
passerais portier je suis tout seul avec
ma mère et mes frères et soeurs
on va dire que je vais bien évidemment
j'ai eu 40 personnes mam est tragique
habitat à notre coin
ym 10 watts et 1,5 qui vit un nom dans
leur vie alors c'est comme ça ça vient
la bagarre et je veux toujours salle
parce que l'autre fois je tombe dans la
boue et c'est pour ça que m'ont traitée
alors moi j'ai des gars qui est un oeil
au werder
début mars la scène dépasse de 6 mètres
la cote d'alerté les derniers habitants
du bidonville fui vers la ville ils y
vivront tant que durera la crue seul ou
presque
l'autocar des sturm est encore habité
des fois je pleure
je ne dépends de france c'est quand je
suis confirme
j'ai pas l'impression de ressembler
fille de mon âge parce que je suis dans
les bidonvilles
on se trouve pas de camarades
j'ai pas envie d'être hantée habite en
ville mais je suis un peu gêné
pour moi elle tombe pas
plus tard j'habiterai dans une maison et
on aura un peu de lumière ce que cela
avait pas fort clair il y aura la douche
tout ça
et oral est récitée on pourra mettre du
lille ou par terre
puis on pourra le ciré tout ça bien
laver
yale maîtresse me demander où j'habitais
que j ai dit que j'habitais un bref avis
dans un autre cas bien m'a dit elle le
savait pas obama pose des questions à ma
demande et le plonger fait qu'elle a dit
c'était très bien
119 bidonvilles dans la région
parisienne quarante mille personnes y
vivent
un souvenir à présent au mois de mars
dernier
notre camarade raymond meyer que vous
voyez à votre gauche sur la photo qui se
trouve derrière - avaient emporté sa
caméra à conflans sainte honorine pour
raconter l'histoire d'une famille qui
vivait dans un autobus la famille tourne
depuis la famille storme a été relogée
notre camarade raymond meyer lui est
mort au cambodge et c'est aussi en
souvenir de lui qu un autre cameraman
d'information première pierre moscovitch
est allé rendre visite pour noël à la
famille storme qui a été relevé
[Musique]
on a vu que dans votre bouche quand même
c'est la première année qu'on sait qu'on
est si nous promet un premier noël pour
fait ici
on a bien ri jang pour moi
c'est bon que j'étais en vue du combat
mené en bateau par à petit et
il va les avoir visité les prix
commencent bon bah c'est pas du coup
pour tout le monde alors je réponds
oui s'appuyant sur sa longue jamais
assez pour
bastide j'ai acheté cette voiture c'est
un baigneur
et à thierry un petit tracteur
tuque ou plus dans le même temps
on a utilisé on ira
pour accoucher du groupe et dans le
temps moi je fasse avec des sur toi
aussi
tu sais si tu es tu
mais bon
c'est
[Musique]
quand même pour faire
il dit aussi programmer avait pas deux
fois je demande à l'image de marié
partis du oui et les bonheurs et en
faire tous les kilomètres afin qu'elle
organise c'est bien gamins y
travaillaient là
pour aider au froid comme il fait là
mais elle était gelée comme aider à
rentrer et cette envie en docx et
viennent d'arriver juste
il appellera combat de café ils vont
embarquer avec nous
mais par
bail a couru jusqu'à la guerre mais dit
c'est pas très grave complot et
prendrait bien ou pour les thèmes et
moins de trains
vous dites on faisait ce qu'on va faire
paris
[Musique]